Let's say that we wanted to compare the batting averages
of left handed and right handed hitters in major league baseball.
So we're curious in answering the question, is there any difference
between the batting averages of lefties and righties? We could just
look at the data and try to answer this question without
a significance test. But then we really couldn't trust our answer
very much. It's a much better idea to answer this question
using a statistical test. Many statistical tests that you might use
to analyze data make an assumption about the probability distribution
that your data will follow. There are many different probability distributions
out there, but one of the most common and the
one that I want to discuss is the normal distribution, which
is also sometimes referred to as the Gaussian distribution or
a Bell curve. If you've taken an introduction to statistics course,
the normal distribution should be familiar. Which of the images below
depicts a normal distribution? Check the box below the correct one.